you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up
with nearly half of france's reactors
offline should the uk be relying on
nuclear power for our future energy
germany's climate envoy tells us the
growing energy crisis in europe is of
huge concern for crucial emissions
targets
[Music]
there is additional pressure that's
coming in right now and i'm worried of
course i'm worried i i see the rise of
emissions we're going in the wrong
direction
and we'll be hearing from model and
environmentalist lily cole on why she
believes universities hold the key to
tackling the climate crisis
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news program where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and report on the race for
solutions
first now half of france's nuclear power
reactors are offline today in the latest
squeeze on european power supplies
france is traditionally one of europe's
biggest electricity exporters and has
the lowest per capita emissions of all
advanced economies due to nuclear power
being a low carbon option
but the dip in output poses difficult
questions for countries such as the uk
who are looking to expand nuclear power
as part of their future energy plans
this time last year nuclear energy was
generating 70 percent of france's
electricity but france's national grid
rte earlier today had the figure at
around 57
that's because 28 of france's 56
reactors have been shut down due to
routine maintenance or defects
well five reactors marked here in black
were shut down after corrosion caused
cracking in the pipe work
remaining 23 plants are down either for
routine yearly maintenance or for safety
reviews it means that france will need
to draw upon power from the european
grid which is already strained from the
energy crisis
well our climate reporter victoria
seabrook is with me to explain more so
really victoria the idea that nuclear is
always on is actually wrong
well that's what critics are saying
they're saying hang on a minute what
happened to this this big selling point
of nuclear is that it's reliable that's
what we hear it's always on and the
other big selling point of course being
that it is um virtually zero carbon and
so
france is potentially finding itself in
this bizarre situation at the moment
where nuclear output is down and so they
are
probably drawing on renewables a bit to
compensate for that and that's ironic
because
the supporters of nuclear often say well
we need it to supplement renewables for
when the sun isn't shining and the wind
isn't blowing
now this all matters to the uk because
the government has just put nuclear at
the heart of its energy security
strategy so this strategy is about the
future of our energy part of it is all
about getting off gas and that's what
this strategy is designed to do and i
spoke to the energy department this week
and they told me that look nuclear it's
not it's not a luxury this is a
necessity it they say it is the only
reliable low-carbon form of power so
they are planning to build eight nuclear
reactors with the idea that they will
generate 25 of britain's power by 2050.
now germany has found itself at the
center of a european energy crisis
dependent on russian fossil fuels for
heavy industry our ambitious climate
targets going to be out of reach our
climate change correspondent hannah
thomas peter has been speaking to
germany's climate envoy jennifer morgan
vladimir putin has stopped gas supplies
to poland and to bulgaria and it has
been labelled as blackmail and a
weaponisation of energy supplies
with your climate envoy hat on what is
your response to that well i think it's
very clear we've been working hard to
phase out um
russian fossil fuels as quickly as
possible as part of a greater effort
uh to phase out fossil fuels because of
the climate crisis and i think that
we will continue on that pathway
um there are many reasons many reasons
to do that
when you look globally
in relation to tackling the climate
crisis how concerned are you that the
war in ukraine
will
prevent
nations
moving forward quickly with their plans
to tackle global warming
well i think the first thing is which is
evident just about every day is that the
climate crisis hasn't gone away
uh even in the midst of this horrific
other set of of the war and other crises
and i think that in my travels around
the world you still see that you still
see that governments understand that and
are trying to move forward however you
know we need to work hard to keep the
momentum because i think that there are
players around the world that will try
and use this moment to build new fossil
fuel infrastructure and lock it in
and we know from the international
energy agency and other and the ipcc
that there's no time actually for new
fossil fuel infrastructure so we have to
remain diligent we have to work in
partnership particularly with the most
vulnerable countries around the world
and we're using our g7 presidency in
every way we can to not lose momentum
because there is additional pressure uh
that's coming in right now and i'm
worried of course i'm worried i i see
the rise of emissions we're going in the
wrong direction
and this has to be a moment where we
come together and accelerate the pace
not only to
have peace but also to have climate
stability germany is building new fossil
fuel infrastructure
new plants to deal with liquid natural
gas
are you concerned that in your own
country
there is going to be an issue with
locking in fossil fuel infrastructure
well certainly this is as i as i said
it's a short-term solution and it's also
what we're looking at is using this
moment which i think you're seeing
around the world the issue of green
hydrogen and infrastructure for green
hydrogen and that anything that we're
doing right now has to be ready for
green hydrogen so we're trying to double
track in a way and bring in accelerate
the pace to green hydrogen
and also to make clear um these aren't
um you know this isn't these aren't
super long-term uh contracts we have the
climate crisis in mind is it easy no is
it necessary absolutely
let's get some of the day's other
climate news now the wildlife trusts
have asked visitors to refrain from
barbecues and to be careful to
extinguish any sources of fires such as
cigarettes this bank holiday that's
because a series of wildfires have
killed wild animals and destroyed large
sways of key nature reserves april has
been notably dry with only around half
the normal amount of rainfall in england
and wales meaning grasslands are
especially prone to catching fire
people across india are bracing
themselves as the extreme temperatures
of the last several weeks are set to
intensify
heat warnings are in place across nearly
all of the country's 28 states with
temperatures forecast to reach 46
degrees in the capital delhi over the
coming days with concerns rising about
how the country's population will cope
with the heat extreme temperatures are
also causing major damage to crops which
are the primary source of income for
hundreds of millions of indians
new data from an energy think tank has
revealed a record amount of electricity
was generated by renewable power sources
in the u.s last month research from
think tank ember revealed that wind and
solar farms generated 18
of u.s electricity in march that's
enough to supply a country the size of
portugal with electricity for a whole
year
now we've talked a lot on this show
about climate in education and the
government recently announced the
introduction of a new natural history
gcse which will be available from 2025.
however there's a lack of awareness
among the public over how much work is
being done on climate issues at
university level earlier i spoke to the
model and environmentalist lilly cole
about a new campaign being launched this
week to highlight the role of
universities in tackling the challenge
the universities uk
have published a report that just came
out that i wrote the forward to
which
looks at climate action that's being
driven by universities across across the
uk
to both celebrate the work that's being
done by students professors universities
and also i think in a way to galvanize
more action because universities are in
a really kind of unique position to play
kind of an important role in the climate
crisis and addressing the climate crisis
both because of university's
responsibility and access to
educating the youth the next generation
but also with kind of unprecedented
unparalleled research facilities
and we're already seeing examples of
that being deployed and universities
kind of helping come up with climate
solutions and hopefully we will see more
more of that
what do you think your climate education
was like when did you start to feel
passionate about climate issues do you
feel like you learned anything about it
in university
it's a good question i mean
i went to cambridge university and i
write in the report about some of the
things cambridge are doing because i
think they've they've really kind of
been doing a lot from what i've seen um
cambridge zero was a group set up by
emily shukba who i'd interviewed for my
book who cares win so i i know a little
bit um and they're trying to use the
different research
kind of multidisciplinary approaches
that the the university has to um to try
and innovate around climate solutions
that was founded i'm just using that as
an example but that was founded after i
was studying at cambridge which is not
to say that there wasn't a kind of
environmental awareness but it
definitely wasn't as dominant as it is
today
and i think that's reflective of just
wider society and the fact that when i
started looking into kind of
environmental issues as a teenager which
is
there i say nearly 20 years ago um
there just was
much less mainstream awareness of the
issues that we're facing
when you were younger and quite early on
in your career you made the move to say
that you didn't want to wear fur that's
quite bold and i think lots of people
said to you aren't you worried about
your career prospects and perhaps not
getting any jobs and
because of your decision what would you
say to anybody who perhaps wants to make
more of a stance on climate but fears
that it may detrimentally impact their
career it may really impact their job
and they're not being supported by their
boss what would you say to them
that it is the future that there is no
fighting science and physics
um and that we we cannot kind of
procrastinate and talk our way out of
the reality of the science and so all
industries have to go this way i mean
the ipcc the inter-panel um inter-panel
governmental sorry intergovernmental
panel on climate change
um say it's now or never to take action
on on the climate crisis and are calling
for transformation transformative change
across all industries um so the state's
never been higher the actions
and the kind of need for action has
never been clearer
and so i just
anybody who actually has a good business
sense sees that the the future lies in
in an alternative pathway
[Applause]
and one more bit of news for you more
than half of britain's polls say they
support the demands being made by
protest group just stop oil the number
of people saying they were likely to
engage in some form of climate action
over the next year also increased by
almost three percent during the protests
just stop oil has been using disruptive
protests to demand the uk government
stop new fossil fuel projects
do stay with us coming up i'll be joined
by alyssa gilbert from the grantham
institute and james streeter executive
chairman of the interclimate network
we'll be discussing the disruptive
protests and whether it's really
effective also how good education might
be key to solving the climate crisis
[Music]
i mean everybody gets abuse online to
some degree and that's not acceptable
but the abuse that women get is often of
a sexualized engendered nature for
instance i'm often sent pictures of
empty egg cartons because i'm a woman in
my 30s making my voice heard in a
predominantly male industry and some men
think that i should stick to making
babies and often for women online abuse
becomes offline abuse very quickly
we are doxxed our personal information
is shared online often
here in the u.s we see swatting where a
swat team is called to someone's house
under a fake bomb threat women are
stalked um and i've had friends who are
active in this space who have had the
fbi show up to their house because there
are legitimate death threats against
them so yes you could learn a lot from
this book in terms of you know i.t
security and physical security but it
really is focused on the specific
threats that women face and how to make
sure that we have an equitable space
online because uh those who are abusing
us who are harassing us wish to silence
us frankly and that shouldn't be
acceptable in 2022 just as it wouldn't
be acceptable if these these insults
these slurs were being shouted at us on
the street or in the workplace well the
first thing i think is just very basic
i.t security making sure you're using
different passwords for all your
accounts you can use a password manager
to do this making sure you've got
two-factor authentication turned on so
that if somebody did get a hold of your
password they'd need another factor to
get into that account um that protects
your personal information and then
there's a little bit more tactical uh
you know tips on how to deal with trolls
online all the different sorts of people
that show up in our twitter mentions or
facebook comments um making sure you're
using the affordances that platforms do
have so using the mute block and report
buttons because those send important
signals to the platforms to tell them
what's going on and that perhaps this
person who's been sending abusive
messages all day long
needs to to endure some sort of
consequence with his or her account um
and then finally it talks about building
a community not just within your peers
and uh colleagues but you know looking
for support among employers it's not
just newsrooms that should be looking
out for their employees in this day and
age we have health care workers we have
you know academics we have lots and lots
of people who use the internet as part
of their jobs and employers need to do a
little bit more to make sure they're
supporting those folks
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news let's discuss
some more of these crucial climate
issues with our guest today alyssa
gilbert director of policy and
translation at the grantham institute
and james streeter from the inter
climate network
so climate change huge issue affects
every area of our lives some people even
suffering with climate anxiety
one way to ease said climate anxiety is
to empower people james let's start with
you that's something that your
organization is working to to do
yes thanks chloe um
let me just explain very briefly
interclimate network is um a uk charity
where we engage young people at
secondary school level
uh and run events
throughout the year um last year we
actually carried out one of the largest
um surveys of young people on climate
change and sustainability
and um
you're absolutely right the the one of
the things we found was the the
challenge with uh
the anxiety
but um and this does come from uh as you
said this sort of powerlessness so it's
really important that action is
something which is promoted as part of
education
so i think the sustainability and
climate change strategy for education is
a good start and the natural history
gcse
will formalize um that
uh part of the education system
uh as opposed to what it's been in the
past which has been uh down to a few
selected individuals
alyssa this is really complicated stuff
there's no simple solutions to climate
change
when do you think we should start
educating youngsters about climate
tissue when's the right time
well i think we should work in the same
way that we do in educating people about
any kind of issue and we start teaching
people the basic principles of asking
questions around science for example at
a very young age to learn the skills and
the ways of thinking that they require
so that they can become talented and
sophisticated scientists at a university
and postgraduate level eventually or
stop somewhere in between and apply
those skills the same is true for
climate change actually working on
climate change issues actually involves
possibly different ways of thinking we
need people to be able to think across
different sectors flexibly solve
problems
those kind of skills we should be
building into education from an early
age
and additionally it's important that
people appreciate and feel
nature
and they understand the environment
around them so the kind of immersive
learning student led approaches all of
these things can be incorporated in the
curriculum from very early on
and i think it was just last week or so
the government published
sustainability and climate change
education strategy or white paper that
came out of the department for education
and that encompasses um aspects of
learning about climate change
right from early years all the way up to
university postgraduate and adult skills
james let's bring you in what sort of
response have you had from students that
you've been working with with the work
that you've been doing
yeah the response has been amazing so
firstly could i just sort of um add to
elissa's answer i think the um
the the
really key point in in education is the
secondary level because climate change
is a complicated subject you need the
students to be at a level where they can
understand and really react and work
with that complexity
and also at secondary level
um yeah
you know you are made by your teacher
and brought along by the school to do
things that you would not necessarily do
yourself when you get to university it
becomes rather self-selective so i think
the um the uh secondary uh education
part is absolutely crucial
now the gcse um i think is great um it's
a good start
but um it's really important that it
cuts across a whole range of subjects
climate change as we're seeing is not
just about any more the biology and the
geography it's about economics it's
about politics it's about engineering
design things like this
and and also um the the importance of of
bringing in the action what we found
um through our survey into climate
network
is that
young people um they their awareness is
increased um as lilly cold mentioned in
her interview that the awareness when
she started was was virtually nothing
but what they want to to know is what to
do uh around climate change for example
what to buy that actually is not
degrading the environment
secondly they um they want to know uh
they want leadership they want the
adults in the room and particularly the
teachers to to walk the talk and show
them what to do
and then i think that um
thirdly here there's um it's about the
buildings and making them actually fit
for the future um if i think if you put
all the schools in the country together
you get an area roughly two times the
size of birmingham so there's a huge
potential there for um you know
mitigation but also there are
opportunities i mean think of the
biodiversity opportunities for example
if if you manage to do something across
that whole area
alyssia just quickly on this um it's not
just the youngsters we've been talking a
lot about youngsters and students is it
it's the whole workforce really we need
to up skill so they can also work in
in climate issues how do we go about
doing that
yeah you're absolutely right it's really
important that we make sure that we have
the skills available and necessary to
actually deliver
the the net zero and resilient future
that we see ahead of ourselves one of
the ways that we can do that is by
making sure that our approach to
education across all ages including
adult education is tightly linked to our
development of the green skills agenda
um and actually the government has been
long promising a green jobs delivery
group which will build on work both on
climate education and on the green jobs
task force so that we can pull together
education with skills as soon as
possible
okay and now let's uh change subject
earlier we were talking about that poll
that found more than half of britain's
so they support the demands being made
by the group just stop oil but perhaps
not their methods um
james let's start with you on on protest
um there's a fine line isn't there
between a protest to make a point and
then criminal activity
yeah absolutely and i think first of all
people should you know we've got to make
it clear
people should be allowed to protest
and um
it is a really good way of democratizing
climate change but you you're spot on it
has to be peaceful and legal
um
unfortunately
what we're finding is it's increasingly
being driven by desperation um people
around see that they the leadership are
not making the decisions and taking the
country in the direction they want
so um i think it's really
it's really important that um that
people
see that protesting comes in different
forms it's not just about the physical
abstraction that we've seen there's also
about schools marching for climate and
also more sophisticated protests such as
a legal challenge
alyssa let's get your opinion on this
recently we saw new laws for police
giving them more powers to take action
at protest do you think that was needed
well
in terms of i just sort of reiterate
what james has said i think
protest and speaking out about climate
change in particular has been actually a
very important way for the public to
actually indicate that the government
was behind on their action this is an
area where if you look towards the
school strikes and fridays for the
future movement of a few years ago that
really woke up politicians to see that
such a large part of the population
really wanted to see faster action on
this issue
i don't think that meant that we need
police activity i think that means that
we need government response to these
issues
alyssa and james thank you so much for
joining us really interesting debate
there
now if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
latest edition of sky news's climate
cast in today's edition samantha
washington speaks to our climate
correspondent hannah thomas peter about
whether the war in ukraine will mean
europe will be forced to abandon climate
ambitions and burn more coal the
dirtiest of polluters you can subscribe
now wherever you get your podcasts
thanks so much for watching see you next
time
[Music]